here's how to play the Golden Girls
drinking game you will need up to three
other friends your favorite alcoholic
beverages and an episode of the best Bea
Arthur based sitcom of all time no not
Maude come on first everyone chooses a
character next agree on a mode of play
there are two possible modes sing or get
sync when playing zing you drink every
time your character Zing's someone I'll
treat my body like a temple yeah well
what's everyone day your life when
playing get zinged you drink every time
your character gets synced I'll treat my
body like a temple yeah all butts
everyone day your life you can tell who
the alcoholics are because they choose
Sofia when playing zing or Rose when
playing get sing watch the episode and
drink with every zing taking shots based
on your character and these special
circumstances
whenever Sophia says picture it picture
it Sicily 1922
whenever Dorothy gives advice whenever
Blanche mentions Big Daddy
I haven't had to disappoint so many
minutes it's daddy tore down the
treehouse or whenever Rose says a
strange word from st. Olaf then there's
the Cheesecake rule if your character
sits at the table eating cheesecake you
have to finish your drink and start
another and finally everyone must sing
the theme song during the credits
please drink responsibly and thank you
for being a friend
[Music]